feylau was one of the division's most
trusted agents
however her mission to avenge the death
of her sister and rid the world of aaron
kina
led her to going rogue and joining the
black tusk
but why did she choose to take this path
and betray the shd
and her fellow agents
feylau is a second generation chinese
american
when she was only 17 years old she
tragically lost both of her parents in a
car accident
resulting in her being tasked with
raising her younger sister heather
on her own records state that this
changed her
certain behavioral traits including
integrity accountability
empathy resilience vision and influence
were enhanced resulting in strong
leadership traits that would assist her
in the years to come however this also
came at the expense of her ability to
gain
and manage personal relationships
while attending city college faye joined
the school's reserve officers training
corps
she used this to help further progress
her career
after a number of positions within
military intelligence
faye was eventually admitted into the
national security agency
where she worked as a part of the
support staff for the director of
national intelligence
after the presidential directive 51 was
signed faye relocated to the newly
formed strategic homeland division
as a senior field officer she would be
reporting directly to the north
eastern section division commander lewis
chang
shortly after the first wave of division
agents disappeared president waller
activated a second wave of agents into
new york city
and ordered commander chang to
personally lead the operations
fae was activated to serve as chang's
second in command
but as the helicopter was approaching
its destination to pick up fae
in the remaining agents of the second
wave it was shot down
and destroyed killing commander chang
and seriously wounding fae
her injuries meant that she had to be
removed from field work
but as feylau was now the most senior
agent in the city
she continued to serve as the acting
division commander
from here she was a primary contact and
strategic support
for all remaining second wave division
agents in new york
pass the division have made vast steps
in regaining control of new york
all major hostile faction leaders have
been killed and a number of parts of the
city were starting to rebuild
furthermore intel suggests that the
first wave rogue agents have left the
city
along with their leader aaron kina
more months pass the division's network
was taken down
and protocol dictated that all available
agents must get to washington dc
as soon as possible but faye made the
choice to stay in new york
to stop them from losing the foothold
they've gained over the months prior
there is an attack on the southern
manhattan jtf outpost
at city hall agents from dc are sent to
investigate
they learn that the attack was
orchestrated by the rogue agent
arankina it has now been over eight
months
since the majority of the division
agents headed to dc and faye had finally
recovered from her injuries
however something else was coming and
this would see faye's whole world
come crashing down a settlement in
hell's kitchen district has been
attacked by rikers
with near to no defensive systems and a
dwindling amount of jtf
to properly guard and patrol the
facilities there were massive casualties
including fei's sister nevertheless
with help from the division agents from
dc she continues the hunt for aaron kina
it was around this time that faye
manages to capture a rogue agent
who just happens to be working for the
black tusk agent alicia coswalt
otherwise known as cersei
the following weeks would see the
division locating and eliminating kena's
rogue agents
and eventually the man himself but even
more shocking
was the revelation from new york's
number one agent
schaefer do you read listening
fall back keener's dead but he's
activated the network
what's the damage
cornell's watch is collating the data
looks like it's all of them
[ __ ] more rogue agents we [ __ ] need
no it's perfect this will bring the
division to its knees
and that's when we'll end them once and
for all
although still apprehensive of the
decision to join up with a black tusk
fay meets up with barden schaefer to
discuss plans going forward
how's it feel comfortable lacks
personality though
easier to spot a friendly in the field
the uniform doesn't guarantee you're a
friendly
fair enough i like your style now
no [ __ ] i think you'll fit in well
here
me too do i get to build my team
are you testing me out with an
established squad are you worried about
getting hazed
i've had to break into boys clubs before
i know how you like to test
people finish this up and we'll talk
about building your own squad
copy that over time
schaefer was eventually hunted down by
her former colleagues and captured
faye took little time in organizing a
meeting with president ellis
this is our chance to shape history
i couldn't agree more mr president you
said it yourself
somebody has to step up i'm willing to
take on that challenge
if we're going to get this country back
on track
we have to be willing to do things that
won't be
popular i know that you and schaefer had
a rather contentious relationship
i hope our collaboration will be more
efficient i look forward to meeting you
in person
that can be arranged excellent
see you soon mr president
what an [ __ ]
after finding out else's whereabouts and
schedule fae caught up with him
at camp white oak and when the time came
without hesitation she gunned him down
where he stood
at this point in time division agents
were already hot on a trail
but she had already rang through
announcing that it was a division that
had taken the president out
so time was of the essence they needed
to catch up with her before they too
were announced as rogue
chasing her through the compound they
eventually caught up with her in the
area that alice himself had once escaped
their grasp
but this time they were prepared
disabling the helicopter
faye was forced to engage the agents
head-on
after a short fight the division was
able to eliminate her supporting btsu
forces although faye certainly brought
the fight
the shd agents had no problem bringing
the full force of their vengeance to the
[Music]
party
let's face it i haven't heard from a
single person that wouldn't agree that
this was a disappointing end to the
manhunt
but based on the trailer and the sudden
announcement from massive that this was
to be the last
update to the division 2 i think that
this isn't the last we're going to hear
of phelau i legitimately believe that we
were supposed to capture fey
similar to what we did with schaefer but
due to the apparent unexpected decision
to extend the division over the next
year or two
they potentially cut the final cinematic
to be expanded on later
this could also be further supported by
the fact that isaac never said anything
of substance when she was dropped
but if theo taught us anything isaac can
be easily manipulated
so who knows however for now let's look
at the facts that have been presented to
us in game
faye lost his sister due to an adequate
jtf resource to look after the
settlements
faye captures and interrogates cersei
aaron keener is killed
followed shortly after with faye being
found out as rogue
barton schaefer is captured by the
division
faye locates president ellis and
executes him blaming it on the division
fey is found and potentially captured by
the division
then there is the last comms that we
received from this manhunt that leads to
the idea that fey is working as an
undercover rogue agent
i know you hate me you never trusted me
you probably never liked me and only
moderately tolerated me
it's okay that's okay we didn't have to
be friends
and i know you probably think i'm a
[ __ ] though you would never actually
say that
that's my face at least i think the
reason we never really got along is
we're too similar
we're stubborn we care too much and
frankly we're both
pretty guarded people we've both
lost people and we didn't deal with that
as well as we could have i guess but
i hope that when i'm done you'll
understand why i did what i had to do
i don't expect you to agree with it but
i hope you understand
i'm not sorry it went down like this but
i'm sorry i couldn't tell you why
hey roy this is hard for me
this is probably the hardest thing i've
ever had to do
you trusted me and i loved you for that
it broke my heart having to keep secrets
like this from you but
i knew i knew if i told you what i was
planning you would try to stop me
and if you tried to stop me there's no
way i could have gone through with any
of it
there's no way i could have interrogated
alicia or met shafer
or gone with him i had to do this
roy i had to we were losing we lost the
authority we lost the trust of the
people we were trying to protect
without trust we have nothing it doesn't
matter how many good or bad things we do
if no one trusts you to get the job done
and with schaefer and ellis we lost the
legitimacy we lost the ability to say
we are on mission health the only one
who agreed we were still on mission was
isaac
i knew what i had to do all i needed was
access
and i couldn't get that unless i joined
them or at least
unless i could make them believe i
joined them
i'm sorry i couldn't tell you why
i'm sorry i had to break your trust like
that
but i hope i i pray you'll forgive me
someday
if you don't i might have to come hot
your ass until you do
out
though if this is true and she is simply
going through all of this to take down
the black tusk asset
prison ellis why did she blame his death
on the division
this leads me into two different trains
of thought
alice is the one responsible for having
the jtf abandoned the quarantine zone
not long after the initial outbreak this
in turn led to many division agents
going rogue
with one notable agent in particular
aaron kina
faye blames kina for his part in the
death of her sister
and alice's part in putting keener in
that position
the division is the last organization
with any ties to the old government
given them claimed to determine what's
right and wrong
it's no secret that faye isn't a fan of
the way that isaac operates
but considering everything that's
happened perhaps faye has finally lost
hope in the government in the shd too
she has come to the conclusion that this
strategic homeland division is a failed
initiative
and that with all the freedom they are
given they still don't have enough
wriggle room under the guidance of isaac
to do what is needed
i don't necessarily think she believes
the black task of the answer
but now that schaefer has been captured
she decided to seize the opportunity
and kill two birds with one stone she
would execute alice
and bring down the shd as witnessed in
warlord of new york
at the haven settlement trust in the
division is already pretty low
the general public is sick of watching
these agents do what they want
and eventually turning rogue and working
against them
with faye blaming the death on the
division that should be enough to push
the remaining settlements over the edge
and without the support of the people
the agency would collapse
this would basically put the division
agents in a position of becoming rogue
agents
whether isaac has flagged them as rogue
or not is redundant
in the eyes of the people they are no
longer allies put in place
to save what remains however i don't
think having each of the agents hunted
down and killed
is what faye actually wants this is
likely just a side effect
of what she's done she may have just
deemed this as acceptable collateral
damage
in her mission of putting the final nail
in the coffin for the old us government
and the shd in fact maybe she was hoping
that they would regroup with her later
on
no longer under the shd control
[Music]
alternatively the second and probably my
preferred direction
faye hasn't lost hope in the government
and she still strongly believes in the
division's mission of saving what
remains
but over time watching this determined
and well-funded new enemy
and the remaining agents around her
either being killed or turning rogue
joining the black tusk ranks
she has come to the conclusion that they
are fighting a losing battle
the only one left in the government is
corrupt and has joined the other side
the chain of command is already broken
it was up to her to take him down
before he was used to bring the general
populace over to their side
faye would go undercover and eliminate
ellis after gaining their trust
she had to do this alone firstly she
didn't know who she could trust anymore
and those she could like benitez
wouldn't allow her to do this on her own
but she had already lost enough loved
ones and didn't want to be responsible
for more of their deaths on her hands
the reason she blamed alice's death on
the division agents was to keep her
cover from being blown
after all schaefer had already been
captured but natalya sokolova was still
out there
and while she was still around the black
tusks are a threat to the country
yes this means that the division has now
been burned but as she had seen them as
only losing ground to this invading
force
it was a sacrifice she had to make on
top of this
given that they are now rogue agents she
may be able to bring more of them
undercover into the btsu
to help in her mission especially once
benitez and rhodes
receive her message fellow decided that
it was up to her to do what no division
agent was able to
and that the only way to do this was to
go rogue join up the black tusk
and take ellis and the rest of his
leadership down from the inside
long story short whatever reasons for
doing what she did
i'm feeling pretty confident that she
isn't dead i'm not completely convinced
of what
and why things played out this way
though i think this is pretty close
there is just a few details that are
missing that i'm guessing we won't hear
about until we get some new content
whenever that is what about you
do you have any theories about what
fellow was doing
otherwise fingers crossed we'll start to
get some proper content to play down the
line
even some news on what's happening would
be nice
anyway thank you very much for watching
and i'll catch you in the next one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
cheers